amplifié et accéléré simplifié ce sont
allés nouveau mot d'ordre de la
stratégie vaccinale de la france contre
le coc vide 19 précision ce matin
d'olivier ferrand le ministre de la
santé qui a tenu à afficher la volonté
du gouvernement d'accélérer la cadence
après avoir essuyé de nombreuses
critiques sur la lenteur de la mise en
place de la campagne de vaccination en
france
olivier ferrand qui a tenté de rassurer
le rythme de croisière du pays va
rejoindre celui de nos voisins européens
ce sont ses mots car la france est à la
traîne sur le nombre de personnes
vaccinées dans le pays
du côté des annonces et bien hier le cap
des 2000 vacciner a été franchie la
liste des personnes éligibles aux
vaccins elle s'élargit petit à petit
après à les soignants de plus de 50 ans
hier place dans les prochains jours aux
pompiers et aux aides soignants aussi un
de plus de 50 ans avant la fin du mois
de janvier les plus de 75 ans qui ne
résident pas dans des ehpad pourront eux
aussi se faire vacciner et puis sachez
que 5 à 600 centres de vaccination
devraient voir le jour à la fin du mois
jean castex étaient aussi sur le front
un pour défendre la stratégie du
gouvernement depuis toulon où il était
en déplacement le premier ministre a
fustigé est des polémiques stériles qui
n'ont jamais sauvé aucune vie ce sont à
ces mots le premier ministre qui a aussi
indiqué qu'il tiendrait une conférence
de presse aux côtés d'olivier véran
jeudi avant un conseil de défense et un
conseil des ministres qui eux
elles se dérouleront est mercredi enfin
sachez qu olivier aveyron sera entendu
au sénat le 12 janvier prochain pour
s'expliquer sur les mesures correctives
mises en place par le gouvernement pour
pallier la lenteur de la france sur le
front de la vaccination